un aumento de 2 grados en la temperatura
global sería una sentencia de muerte
para las maldivas
posicionaba tan solo 1,5 metros sobre el
nivel del mar las maldivas es un país
formado por casi 1200 islas repartidas
en 90.000 kilómetros de océano por su
posición geográfica y baja altitud una
subida del nivel del mar podría poner a
diferentes partes del país bajo el agua
los científicos de nequion Mission de
Reino Unido están explorando partes del
océano que nadie había visto antes
tienen como objetivo recopilar los datos
sobre la vida Marina desde la superficie
hasta los 1000 metros y determinar la
salud del océano
maldivas es un país que tiene un 99% de
océanos también está en la primera línea
de la crisis climática los habitantes de
las maldivas han hecho muy poco para
provocar la crisis climática pero el
nivel del océano está subiendo y va a
afectar primero a los lugares como este
todo mientras las principales potencias
buscan limitar el calentamiento global a
1,5 grados centígrados algo que expertos
prevén que no se logrará para final de
siglo si no se ajustan las políticas de
los principales emisores de carbono del
mundo
el problema no es la falta de tecnología
el problema no es la financiación el
problema Es la falta de voluntad
política y por eso creo que necesitamos
que los líderes políticos tomen una
decisión Audaz para abordar este
problema
se espera que con la misión británica se
proteja por lo menos el 20% del
territorio oceánico en un país donde más
del 70% depende del agua que lo rodea
para gestionar sus ingresos